اكملت اسرته فيصل الاجراءات المطلوبه للحج
هذا العام في انتظار السفر الى الديار
المقدسه انتظار يخشى فيصل وعائلته ان يمتد
لفتره طويله في ظل الاوضاع الامنيه التي
تعيشها البلاد
نحن نمشي او لا
اما اسيا وهي في العقد السابع من عمرها
فتكبدت مشقه السفر من الخرطوم الى ولايه
الجزيره من اجل اكمال اجراءات الحج بعد ان
تعذر ذلك في الخرطوم تقول اسيا انها كانت
على وشك الانتهاء من اجراتها في الخرطوم
قبل ان تبدا الحرب ويحدوها الامل في ان
تصل الى الاراضي المقدسه لاداء فريضه الحج
ضرب لنا يوم الخميس قالوا لنا يوم السبت
تجي تورده يوم السبت طوالي حصل الحرب
ما عرفنا اي حاجه بس الليله سمعنا قالوا
الجزيره لا تخرطومات جزيره طوال الجزيره
الجزيره الحمد لله ساعدونا كل الاجراءات
اكتمل بعد اكتمال اجراءات معظم المتقدمين
للحج هذا العام من هذه الولايه او
القادمين اليها من ولايه الخرطوم تبقى
عمليات التفويج وهي مرحله تختلف عن
الاعوام الماضيه للمسافرين جوا بسبب تعليق
العمل في مطار الخرطوم
هنا في ولايه الجزيره شرعت اداره الحج
والعمره في تنسيق اجراءات الحج منذ شهر
رمضان وبعد المواجهات المسلحه في الخرطوم
بدات الولايه متابعه اوضاع المتقدمين للحج
من العاصمه والولايات المجاوره وتترقب
اداره الحج والعمره في الولايه بدا تفويج
الحجاج الى الموانئ والمطارات البديله
التي تحددها السلطات بناء على التطورات
الامنيه على الارض
ستشهد الايام القادمه ان شاء الله عن
المدرسه بتاع التفويض بشكل
مرتب بشكل راتب والناس تواصلت مع كل
الشركات الشركات النقل الوطنيه وبحمد الله
كلهم ابدو استعداد والتعاون التام لنقل
حجاج بيت الله الحرام للحج
1444 بلغت حصه السوداني هذا العام من
الحجاج اكثر من ثلاثين الفن يغادرون الى
الاراضي المقدسه عبر ميناء السواكن البحري
في شرق السودان باتجاه ميناء جده البحري
ثم يتبعهم حجاج اخرون من ميناء بورسودان
الجوي وكلاهما يتطلب سفرا طويلا يمتد
لمئات الكيلومترات للقادمين من ولايات وسط
وجنوب البلاد وكان مجلس الحج والعمره قد
شكل لجانا لمعاليه اوضاع حجاج اقليم
دارفور الذي شهد احداثا امنيه هيثم
الجزيره مدينه مدني